one more Trump thing I want to talk
about Donald Trump posted and endless
back-to-back truth statement on his
platform truth social truth Central yeah
and
it is absolutely absurd and it relates
to the Stormy Daniels Affair and it also
relates to Donald Trump's impending
indictment or indictments that Global uh
that legal Scholars increasingly believe
are coming I'm not holding my breath but
there are legal Scholars who believe the
indictments are coming
take a look at this insanity this is
multiple truths okay this was over the
weekend this is Trump now I'm I'm
speaking As Trump I did absolutely
nothing wrong I never had an affair with
Stormy Daniels nor would I have wanted
to have an affair with Stormy Daniels
that's a lie now is he saying is this a
semantic argument I didn't have an
affair with her but I did engage in
sexual relations with her he did pay her
off for her silence so why would you do
that if you didn't it doesn't make any
sense so he's already lying he says this
is a political Witch Hunt trying to take
down the leading candidate by far in the
Republican Party while at the same time
also leading all Democrats in the polls
including Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
Congress and numerous Democrat District
Attorneys Attorneys General and thee
then it continues on another truth
Department of Injustice itself which has
unprecedentedly placed top doj
prosecutors into the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office in order to quote get
Trump have found that I did nothing
wrong
that's not true by the way there were
prosecutors who were convinced Trump did
do things wrong but that nobody was
going to indict him and those
investigators quit back to Trump now
they fall back on the old and rebuked
case which has been rejected by every
prosecutor's office that has looked at
this stormy horse face Daniels matter
where I Rely relied on counsel in order
to resolve this extortion of me which
took place a long time ago since then I
have won lawsuits continuing on to
another Truth for hundreds of thousands
of dollars against Stormy Daniels and
every prosecutor's office which has
looked at it which are numerous
including the FEC have turned this fake
case down this is not a state case it is
a federal case and they have all passed
on it even the previous Manhattan D.A
Cyrus Vance did not bring charges
because I am guilty of nothing except
for the fact that I am beating all
Republicans and Democrats badly in the
presidential race it is Russia Russia
Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine the no
collusion Mueller hoax and other
targeted false attacks against me all
over again
it is a weaponization of our judicial
system and I am shocked that this
soros-backed radical left prosecutor who
has allowed violent crime to reach New
Heights in New York without any
retribution would consider bringing such
a charge against the Undisputed
front-runner of one of the two major
political parties in our Capital land
Nation
folks I'm out of breath but this is
insane this is a completely insane
statement to put out it's it's a
Rorschach test it's a verbal ink plot
Additionally the statute of limitations
has long since ended and in fact radical
left media one and a half years ago did
a countdown on the statute of
limitations which was allowed to expire
the countdown ended until now nobody had
any idea it was allowed to continue in
this one low ball office
it is appalling that the Democrats would
play this card and only means that they
are certain that they cannot win at the
voter Booth so they have to go to a tool
that has never been used in such a way
in our country weaponized law
enforcement now about by the way
um it's prosecutors and investigators
that would be doing this Democrats
aren't doing anything
Trump continues I and hundreds of
millions of the American people who are
backing me Trump doesn't have hundreds
of millions of backers by the way
because they want to see our nation be
great again are the victims of this
corrupt depraved and weaponized justice
system where Hunter Biden and his father
can commit horrendous crimes all
accurately documented on his laptop and
nothing happens but with me after
looking at 11 million Pages worth of
documents they go after a hoax that
every other prosecutor's office which
reviewed it and even the U.S Congress
has long ago dropped I will not be
deterred I will always continue to be
your voice and I will keep fighting for
our great Capital C country
this is what we are to expect if this
continues and Donald Trump's candidacy
continues unhinged lie filled bizarre
endless statements almost completely
unintelligible this is not someone who
is well but he is by far as of today the
front runner to be the 2024 Republican
primary nominee I've said it before and
I will say it again sure
Trump's whacked out of his gourd I get
it but what does it say about his
followers that after everything that's
happened
he puts out these tirades these screeds
and it still allows him to maintain
support from many of the people who
supported him in 2020. it says more
about his followers than it says about
Trump
one of our sponsors is private internet
access most apps and websites send tons
of your personal information to tech
companies and data Brokers based on your
IP address they have a disturbingly
accurate understanding of who you are
and what you do online even when you're
using incognito mode but you can put an
end to it by using a VPN the only one I
use is private internet access because
it's the only VPN that has proven in
court multiple times they are not
logging your activity they're no log
practices are even independently audited
by Deloitte private internet access also
hides your activity from your internet
service provider who is also usually
logging everything you do Online private
internet access is also lightning fast
for downloads and streaming content
normally only available in other
countries private internet access
couldn't be more simple take a second to
download it turn it on that's it you
don't need to know anything about
computers go go to Pia vpn.com Pacman to
get 83 off that's only 203 a month and
you'll get four months free the link is
down below